He went from one of the top 100 movie stars of all time...
...to a controversial Hollywood personality.
Welcome to WatchMojo.com and today we'll be taking a look at the legendary career of superstar actor Tom Cruise.
I feel the need, the need for speed!
Born on July 3rd, 1962 in Syracuse, New York,...
...he spent his childhood moving between dozens of homes and schools...
...until settling in Glen Ridge, New Jersey at the age of 14.
There, he developed a deep passion for acting...
...that surpassed his longtime desire to join the priesthood.
As a result, he dropped out of high school...
...and headed back to New York to pursue a career as an actor.
He quickly made his film debut with a small part in the 1981 drama/romance "Endless Love."
Later that year, he got a larger role alongside Sean Penn...
...as a gung ho cadet in the military film "Taps"...
...and appeared in Francis Ford Coppola's film adaptation of "The Outsiders."
Well, we're taking Evie and Sandy,...
...which means no kids allowed.
Big deal.
In 1983, Cruise suddenly found himself overwhelmed with acting work.
That year, he got his first starring role in the comedy "Losin' It"...
...before achieving instant stardom for dancing in his briefs in "Risky Business."
He then became a huge box office draw...
...and was paid half a million dollars to star in Ridley Scott's fantasy film "Legend,"...
...and four times that for the role of fighter pilot Lieutenant Pete "Maverick" Mitchell...
...in 1986's blockbuster "Top Gun."